comme beaucoup d'entre vous,
je pense à cette image.
J'avais 8 ans quand j'ai vu Neil Armstrong
sortir du Module Lunaire et poser le pied sur la Lune.
Je n'avais jamais rien vu de tel auparavant,
et je n'ai rien vu de comparable depuis.
Nous sommes allés sur la Lune pour une seule raison :
John Kennedy s'était engagé à le faire.
Et sans cet engagement,
nous serions toujours en train d'en rêver.
Léonard Bernstein disait qu'il faut deux choses pour faire un grand succès :
un plan, et pas assez de temps pour le réaliser.
(Rires)
Les échéances et les engagements
sont les leçons essentielles tirées d'Apollo.
Ce sont elles qui donnent son sens à l'expression « viser la lune ».
Notre monde a désespérément besoin de leaders politiques
désireux de poser des objectifs ambitieux
pour réaliser de grands rêves, à l'échelle de ce qu'était Apollo.
Quand je pense à nos rêves,
je pense aux drag queens de Los Angeles et Stonewall
et aux millions d'autres gens qui ont tout risqué
en faisant leur « coming out » à un moment où c'était vraiment dangereux,
et à cette image de la Maison Blanche éclairée aux couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel,
oui --
(Applaudissements)
célébrant le droit des homosexuels américains à se marier.
C'est une image que je n'aurais jamais imaginé voir dans mes rêves les plus fous,
quand j'avais 18 ans
et que j'ai réalisé que j'étais gay,
me sentant étranger dans mon propre pays
et dans mes rêves, à cause de cela.
Je pense à cette image de ma famille,
que je n'avais jamais rêvé avoir --
(Applaudissements)
et à nos enfants tenant cette une,
le verdict de la Cour Suprême, que je n'avais jamais rêvé voir imprimé.
Nous avons besoin de plus de ce courage qu'ont eu astronautes et drag queens.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais je voudrais vous parler du besoin que nous avons tous de rêver
dans plusieurs dimensions,
car il y a une chose sur Apollo que je ne savais pas à 8 ans.
Idem sur l'organisation derrière cet arc-en-ciel.
Parmi les 30 astronautes des programmes Mercury, Gemini et Apollo,
seulement 7 mariages ont survécu.
Ces images icôniques des astronautes rebondissant sur la Lune
masquent l'alcoolisme et la dépression sur Terre.
Thomas Merton, le moine trappiste,
a demandé à l'époque d'Apollo :
« Qu'avons-nous à gagner à naviguer vers la Lune
si nous ne sommes même pas capables de traverser l'abysse qui nous sépare ? »
Et que pouvons-nous gagner avec le droit au mariage
si nous ne sommes pas capables de dépasser l'acrimonie
et la distance émotionnelle qui nous séparent si souvent de notre amour ?
Et cela ne concerne pas que le mariage.
J'ai vu les luttes les plus difficiles et les plus destructrices
pour la cause LGBT, le SIDA,
le cancer du sein, l'activisme associatif,
tout cela au nom de l'amour.
Thomas Merton a également écrit sur les guerres parmi les saints
et qu'il y avait « une forme de violence contemporaine envahissante
à laquelle l'idéaliste succombe le plus facilement :
l'activisme et le surmenage.
Notre militantisme neutralise notre travail pour la paix.
Cela détruit notre propre aptitude à la paix. »
Trop souvent, nos rêves deviennent ces obsessions fragmentées
d'un certain futur
qui détruit notre capacité à vivre nos propres vies au présent.
Nos rêves d'une meilleure vie pour un certain futur de l'humanité
ou pour une autre humanité dans un autre lieu
nous privent de la beauté de la personne que nous côtoyons
en ce moment même.
Nous disons que c'est juste la rançon du progrès.
On peut aller sur la Lune
ou avoir une vie de famille équilibrée.
Et nous ne pouvons pas concevoir de rêver les deux en même temps.
Et nos ambitions dépassent rarement la simple stabilité
quand cela touche notre vie émotionnelle.
Et c'est pour cela que notre technologie pour parler à l'autre
s'est drastiquement développée,
notre capacité à écouter et comprendre l'autre
n'a pas décollé.
Notre accès à l'information est quasi illimité,
notre accès à la joie est minimal.
Mais cette idée que notre présent et notre futur sont mutuellement exclusifs,
que pour atteindre notre potentiel d'action, nous devons abandonner
notre potentiel d'existence,
que le nombre de processeurs dans un circuit peut être doublé et doublé,
mais que notre capacité de compassion, d'humanité, de sérénité et d'amour
est en quelque sorte limitée,
est un choix erroné et étouffant.
Je ne suis pas en train de suggérer
qu'il suffit simplement de bien équilibrer sa vie entre travail et famille.
Que puis-je retirer de passer plus de temps avec mes enfants
si mon esprit est ailleurs pendant que je suis avec eux ?
Je ne parle pas non plus de pleine conscience,
c'est devenu tout à coup un outil d'amélioration de la productivité.
(Rires)
N'est-ce pas ?
Je parle de rêver
aussi loin dans la dimension de notre être
que nous le faisons à propos de la technologie.
Je parle d'une authenticité audacieuse
qui nous permet de pleurer ensemble,
une humilité héroïque qui fait tomber nos masques et nous rend vrais.
C'est de notre incapacité à être l'un avec l'autre,
de notre peur de pleurer ensemble, que naissent autant
des problèmes que nous essayons désespérément de résoudre,
depuis le blocage du Congrès jusqu'à l'inhumanité de l'économie.
(Applaudissements)
Je parle de ce que Jonas Salk appelait l’Ère B,
une nouvelle ère dans laquelle nous deviendrons aussi excités, curieux
et scientifiques pour étudier le développement de notre humanité
que nous le sommes pour celui de notre technologie.
Nous ne devrions pas reculer devant l'opportunité
simplement parce que nous ne la comprenons pas vraiment.
A une certaine époque, nous ne comprenions pas l'espace.
Ou parce que nous sommes plus habitués à la technologie et l'activisme.
Cela ressemble à la définition même d'une zone de confort.
Nous imaginons confortablement des succès technologiques inouïs.
En 2016, c'est la dimension d'être nous-mêmes
qui réclame sa part de notre pouvoir d'imagination.
Nous sommes tous ici pour rêver,
mais peut-être, en étant honnêtes,
chacun de nous poursuit son propre rêve.
Chacun de nous cherche ceux qui peuvent l'aider dans ses propres rêves,
parfois en regardant à travers l'humanité de l'autre.
Ne me dérangez pas maintenant. J'ai une idée pour sauver le monde.
N'est-ce pas ?
(Rires)
Il y a des années, j'avais cette superbe société
qui créait des parcours pour des engagements civiques héroïques.
Et nous répétions ce mantra :
« Humain. Bon. Sois les deux. »
Et nous encouragions les gens à expérimenter cette bonté.
Genre : « Allez aider tout le monde à monter leur tente. »
Et il y avait beaucoup de tentes.
(Rires)
« Va acheter des glaces pour tous. »
« Va les aider à regonfler leurs pneus
même si tu sais que tu seras en retard pour dîner. »
Et les gens faisaient ce qu'on leur demandait,
si vous aviez un pneu crevé sur la marche pour le SIDA,
il était difficile de le réparer, car trop de gens vous demandaient
si vous aviez besoin d'aide.
Pendant quelques jours, pour des dizaines de milliers de gens,
on a créé ces mondes
et chacun rêvait que le monde soit toujours ainsi.
Pourquoi n'essayerions-nous pas de créer ce type de monde
dans les jours à venir ?
Et plutôt que de demander à quelqu'un « Que faites-vous ? »,
demandez-lui : « Quels sont vos rêves ? »
ou « Quels sont vos rêves brisés ? »
TED comme « Tend to Each other's Dreams » (Tendre vers les rêves de chacun).
(Applaudissements)
Peut-être est-ce « Je veux rester sobre »,
« Je veux construire une cabane dans les arbres pour mes enfants. »
Ou peut-être, au lieu d'aller vers celui que tout le monde veut rencontrer,
allez vers celui qui est seul
et demandez-lui s'il veut partager un café.
Je crois que ce que nous craignons le plus
est qu'on nous refuse l'opportunité d'atteindre notre vrai potentiel,
que nous sommes nés pour rêver
et que nous pourrions mourir sans avoir pu le faire.
Imaginez vivre dans un monde
où nous reconnaîtrions simplement cette peur profonde en chacun de nous,
où nous nous aimerions avec audace parce que nous savons
qu'être humain, c'est vivre dans cette peur.
Il est temps pour nous de rêver dans de multiples dimensions.
En un lieu transcendant toutes les choses merveilleuses
que nous pouvons et devons faire,
réside notre capacité à réaliser des choses incroyables.
Il est temps pour nous d'entrer dans cette dimension
et d'accepter que nous aussi, nous avons des rêves.
Si la Lune pouvait rêver,
je pense que cela serait son rêve pour nous.
C'est un honneur d'être avec vous.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)